[Music]
dark patterns are features of interface
design crafted to trick users into doing
things that they might not want to do
but which benefit the business in
question here's an example have you ever
tried to delete your Amazon account
here's the Amazon homepage what's the
first thing you might think to do the
obvious place to look is the account
drop down here once you're in here you
look around it's a lot of information
but if I'm interested in deleting my
account I think that your account is
probably a good place to go once I'm on
this page there's a lot more information
payment options login and security and a
bunch of stuff down here unfortunately
you could click every link on your
account page but none would deliver you
to a place where you could actually
delete it
because it's not here in order to
actually delete your Amazon account you
have to go all the way down to the
bottom of the page and under let us help
you click help once you're in here you
have to navigate to need more help
because you know putting it on this page
would just be too easy then click
contact us this is where it starts to
get ridiculous and still nowhere to be
seen but of the four options on the top
that you want help with click prime or
something else you want to something
else in this tell us more about your
issue drop down there's still nothing
that suggests account deletion you just
have to know to click login and security
and then in a second drop down there it
is the magic button close my account
except in order to actually do that you
now have to have a chat conversation
with an Amazon associate who's going to
tell you all the reasons a count elysion
is a bad idea
see you can't delete the account
yourself they have to do it for you this
is a dark pattern a crappy user
experience that intentionally makes it
difficult almost impossible without help
to do something that hurts
Amazon UX specialist Harry brignall
categorizes the specific kind of dark
pattern as a roach motel a design that
makes it very easy for you to get into a
situation but very hard to get out
brignall is actually the one who coined
the term dark pattern in 2010 and he's
been cataloguing and lecturing about the
issue ever since many of these dark
patterns were all familiar with I only
have to search my email for a few
seconds to find one for example here I'm
getting
spam emails from Architectural Digest I
scroll down and look at that this is a
mess but it's a mess on purpose the
unsubscribe link is here but it's
devilishly hard to see that's because
it's the same font and virtually the
same color as the rest of the fine print
here's another dark pattern that uses
color to misdirect over at the user
testing block Jennifer Jerome points out
that the mobile game two dots carries
you through the experience by offering
green buttons a green button to start
the game a green button to pick a level
a green button to start the level and
three green buttons to continue to the
next level and so on but once you lose a
level the color scheme changes the first
screen button you see leads you right to
an in-app purchase while the continue
button is just a little X that blends
into the larger element I wonder how
many people clicked buy moves
reflexively as a Pavlovian response now
to be fair this is a pretty benign dark
pattern but it shows how companies can
use something as simple as color to
trick you into doing what they want on
the more egregious end of the spectrum
you have stuff like this banner ad for
chat most which is made to look like it
has a speck of dust on it causing people
to brush it away and accidentally click
the link or you have sites like
booking.com
where they do everything in their power
to increase the urgency of a purchase
going so far as to alert you in big red
notifications of the hotel rooms that
you just missed that you better book now
you don't want to be left behind again
do you every once in a while a company
goes a little too far and actually
breaks the law remember when you used to
get spam with all those LinkedIn invites
from friends well that was because of a
confusing dark pattern on their ad
contacts page which allowed LinkedIn to
scoop up people's email contacts and
send them messages repeatedly without
their consent in a comprehensive blog
post and schlosser showed how LinkedIn
tried to trick users eight times and
their sign up in onboarding procedures
into surrendering their email contacts
unfortunately for LinkedIn this proved
to be a step too far users filed a legal
challenge claiming that sending multiple
unwarranted emails hurt their
professional reputation LinkedIn settled
the dispute for thirteen million dollars
which came out in the end to about ten
dollars per user it's rare for dark
patterns
face consequences like these mostly they
stay just on the right side of the law
understanding that it's hard to
legislate around the psychological
tricks of UX design everything on the
internet is fighting for your attention
but there's a difference between those
who are taking the time to build trust
and loyalty and the special offer you
clicked which actually enrolled you in a
monthly subscription or the social
network that dark patterned you into
letting it sell data that you didn't
even know it had some of the
responsibility is on us but some is on
design too and it's not the fault of the
designers they're just doing what
they're tasked to do knowing full well
that if they don't others will as
brignall says our best defense against
the dark patterns is to be aware of them
and shame the companies who utilize them
design is what mediates our interaction
with the Internet it's the language we
read it in it's not too much to ask that
that language be comprehensible and
honest hey everybody thank you so much
for watching this episode was brought to
you by Nord VPN now if you care like I
do a lot about your privacy and security
online you should absolutely be using a
VPN or a virtual private network to keep
your data safe by allowing you to
connect to stuff remotely so that prying
eyes can't see your IP address and
private information personally I've had
a few hacking scare so VPNs really
helped ease my mind when I'm online and
Nord VPN is the best out there
Bar None if you're watching this right
now you can get 77 percent off a three
year plan by visiting Nord VPN comm
slash nerdwriter or using the promo code
nerdwriter at checkout I've shopped
around in this space and used a few VPNs
Nord VPN is definitely my favorite by a
mile not only does it have
military-grade encryption and a thousand
servers in 61 countries you can run it
simultaneously on up to six devices
which means you can run it on your
computers and your phone so that when
you're accessing Wi-Fi and a cafe which
I do a lot or a restaurant or an airport
you know you'll be safe and again nor
VPN is offering my viewers 77% off three
plans just go to WWE bien comm /
nerdwriter or click the link in the
description below to sign up and start
protecting yourself thanks guys I'll see
you next time